we're all obsessed with uh diy design
hacks on tick tock i mean i'll take a
hack anywhere um but sometimes they
don't always go as planned um and this
one was posted
by design influencer meredith co who
attempted to create like a sleek and
modern planter with clay but it turns
out there were just a few cracks in the
process literally
literally check this out
[Music]
okay
so meredith is here now hello
meredith um so this tick tock went super
viral
um what went wrong um well the paint
didn't work out
uh then i tried clay and it was air dry
clay so i woke up the next morning and
it was just totally correct well i want
to help you fix your diy design faux pas
in a little segment we're kicking off
today by the way calling hack attack
[Applause]
and i invited someone here today to help
please welcome celebrity interior
designer and drew crew member
it's mikael welsh
thank you for having me
oh macale we're a family this is
ridiculous i go to you for everything
yes um are you ready to tag team on this
mission i'm so so ready meredith girl
we're gonna help you okay thank you i
need it
all right so let's get started so we've
got our styrofoam rounds here right so
i've already kind of started here but i
want you to take one round and then grab
your glue gun
i love it got the glue gun and we just
want to go right around the top of our
little round and just keep going and you
just want to make sure that you have
enough glue that's covering the entire
circle now what are these these are just
styrofoam rounds you know like and where
do you buy them like at any like floral
store you'll see them like for wreaths
around like christmas and holiday time
this is kind of like how they start off
okay oh that's so interesting yeah you
might have to fight the church ladies
for them because they like to pick these
all up all times a year but you can find
them i love that all right now we've got
everything together right is everything
sticking together yes oh my god
i'm good that glue is serious it is
serious so now we're going to move to
another serious step now meredith yes
before you use that clay right yes we're
not going to do that anymore so what
we're going to do is we're going to
apply a little bit of primer per se so
this is a kiehl's primer and basically
it's just like an opaque sealant and
we're just going to go right onto the
front of the piece right just like this
meredith you're paying attention girl
yes okay this is for you i'm just making
sure all right so i just want to make
sure that you're going around the piece
super super even just making sure that
everything is coated and i want you to
put this down because we will let it dry
i would say most like kills primer so
you can let it go for about 30 minutes
to an hour just do a little finger test
make sure it's good to go she's really
dedicated to this process yeah i'm all
right so next once it's dry we're going
to step over to the tv magic and you
should now see the fully primed piece
that is clay free meredith
and so now that that is dry the next
thing that you'll want to do is you want
to apply a coat of your favorite color
of paint and we're going to go right
onto the piece again just covering up
the entire pot we're going to call it a
pot now because these styrofoam pieces
have now become a pot
and honestly you know this is one of
those fun little projects that you can
do at home on the weekend even after
work or for those who work at home and
you're tired of listening to your boss
talk you can just do this like you know
just block out your face on the zoom
call and just keep going
don't tell him i said it do it but by
the way how awesome is mikael by the way
you are like
all right how we looking down there
i i i think it's going well and i think
that this yours is looking good once
you're done with this the final product
will look like our pieces that we have
here on the end our little beauties
which
look like those high-end pots that you
would see in any furniture store and
then the best thing about it if you want
you can even add like a little plant box
inside you can add up some dirt you can
put some succulents like whatever you
want to do you can just really have fun
with it she is really dedicated meredith
is this like gelling with you yes
definitely
love to hear that love to hear that now
meredith what's your next dream project
in the process of redoing our guest
bedroom
so
and kell and i love to make a room over
we do
we do
all right we have these simple steps and
supply lists on the drewbramershow.com
and i want to thank you mikael because
you help us you know in success and
failure and that's what we all know
anytime and everything in between ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]